everybody loves lucy i love lucy thank
you love lucy
yes i do thinking back over all the
years of the i love lucy shows is there
always one particular thing that comes
to mind is the happiest memory from all
of it no but they're about eight or ten
give me the nicest one the happiest
moment i suppose was the baby show ricky
this is it
[Applause]
i'd have to mention that because i was
really having a baby it was really my
last show before i had the baby and it
was for real and it was the most
exciting thing in my life but what's the
real reason for the success of i love
lucy it was a marriage of several things
not just the cast but the writers the
producer there was identification with
an american audience
but with
audiences all over the world we found
out they didn't have to understand the
language to understand the predicament
and the way i got in the way i got out
and the love at the end we always had a
happy ending and domestic situations are
very easily identified all over the
world and that was our great thing that
and the fact that we had an audience
always as a barometer the audience was a
cross-section of america and seemingly
a cross-section of the world
[Applause]
[Music]
you still laugh when you watch i don't
laugh
but i i cry a little why
because they're gone
and good memories they were wonderful to
work with vivian was sensational bill
was sensational the entire operation was
innovative
and great when did you know it was going
to be as big as it was
not until about two or three years were
there scary moments at the very
beginning that it might not run for as
long as it no no we had no scary moments
because we didn't expect to run we
expected to do it for about a year a
minute would all be over be something
that i could show my baby as as home
movies we had no plans nobody knew
anything about television
so we weren't disappointed it was all a
big surprise
[Applause]
how unlike the character are you in real
life i'm not quite a scatter brain
i'm not as scheming
and i'm not as clutzy but a lot of lucy
who went into lucy it's bound to after a
while what did you do to make certain
that you didn't go off the tracks in
this town i just kept on working
i had no plan i had no
format for that i only had a format for
my show and i had great people and i
didn't want to lose them and i kept them
working and we all we kept each other
working
and on our toes we did the best we could
we were happy in our work lucy you said
that one of the reasons why i love lucy
started was to keep you and desi
together it was to have a family and
liverpool you cannot have a baby
over the telephone long distance i found
that out
so i love lucy brought you together
what was it that pulled you apart
i think jesse did such a fantastic job
for so many years and worked so hard
and and destiny does nothing in
moderation he uh
worked hard he was a great innovator he
was a great businessman he was a great
showman and he also played hard are you
still close even though you did barry
talk to him practically
about three times a week
children are very close
we never had a
un
pleasant moment we didn't even get two
lawyers when we got divorced
are you tired run down listless
do you pop out a party
are you unpopular
did you find yourself growing up and
growing as a woman while you were doing
it no i got more childish
and happier when you are doing bigger
than life things that are unbelievable
you have to believe so you're believing
unbelievable things
and you have to use a child-like quality
daily to get through that and make it
honest i've never been asked that before
i'm glad i had an answer
[Applause]
[Music]